getting certain material design
I'm James Williams I'm a senior content
developer at Udacity and a little bit
about me I wrote a book on html5 game
programming that's really really old so
you shouldn't buy it because I only get
like a dollar from it anyway
I create Android and web courses at
Udacity and on the weekends I do Spartan
races and I got this job by accidentally
crashing a party so and here's just my
shameless plug take our courses at
Udacity we have a bunch of courses that
are available for free and my internet
is weird so just assume that that's a
page loading but we have a bunch of
courses that are available for free on
android development web development and
then we also have some other courses on
iOS development that we didn't do with
Google so go and do that stuff so the
target audience for this talk is a
person who has developed an Android app
villus isn't very code heavy but it kind
of uses some terminology from that
understands general Android layouts and
contains enough design to get you moving
that's my Wi-Fi coming on sorry about
that ok come on
okay are you done all right what is okay
all right so just quick show of hands
how many of you guys have developed an
Android app before cool well and some of
you kids have too sweet for you guys we
also have a Android for beginners course
that we just launched a couple months
ago so go check that out
how many designers in the room great so
no one can correct me if I'm wrong so
what I'm going to talk about is
obviously material design and then go
over two different components of
material design surfaces both graphic
design meaningful motion and adaptive
design
none of those last two because they
built a lot on the api's that came
before material design before Android
lollipop that would be kind of a short
shorter summary of those so what is
material design material design is a
design language from Google that
combines elements of print design motion
design digital paper light and shadow to
make cross-platform apps
it is a set of guidelines so you'll hear
a caveat for me a lot in this talk that
this is what you should do but if you
need to do something else that better
fits your app then go and do it so why
should you use in your apps you should
use it because users yell at you if you
don't they will post nasty grams on
nasty messages on your Google Play
reviews and says this app is not
material and all that stuff so use it so
here's a link to the spec and the
general design site from Google so the
first thing we're going to talk about is
surfaces
so surfaces are one dip thick raising
hands do people know what a dip is here
yes no okay so a dip is a so a long long
time ago there was this phone the
t-mobile g1 which has which was
introduced back in 2008 I believe and
the screen gun this phone looks really
really bad the density on it it's 160
dots per inch so a dip is a physical
pixel on that screen phone so that's
where dips come from and go back to the
sky so anyway so there one dip thick
they exist in 3d space because they're
digital sheet of paper they can cast
shadows on one another and be moved with
changes in elevation they can also be
combined or split apart and here is low
visualizer demo is my Wi-Fi on please be
on okay it is not okay I'm going to
switch to the BlueStacks and sorry about
this Wi-Fi kind of happens
switch back okay let's see if that works
now okay so here we go have stopped
jumping in front all right look at down
it all right so we have a material kind
of a sample material app this would be
what shows up in Android studio if you
just create a blank app so it has a
little button down here a title bar and
you can see how this is several surfaces
the menu bar here is its own surface
this background is a surface and this
button here is a surface
alright get up
alright cool alright something that you
shouldn't do you shouldn't just
automatically create your own elevations
the design spec is very specific on what
Heights things should have so go to that
link there and it will show you the
heights of everything on your screen and
it's kind of a long list of things and
I'm gonna skip that alright so one of
the things I showed up there was a
floating action bar bullying action bar
should serve as a primary action for
your app it's not needed for every
single app if you don't have something
that your users doing 80 percent of the
time you shouldn't have a floating
action bar and there should be at most
one bullying action bars come in two
different sizes 56 dips and 40 dips 56
dips is the size that you should use
generally you can use the forty dip size
if the app if the requirements of your
app kind of allow it if it just looks
weird to have a 56 dip floating action
button and the strings for those are
normal and mini so to add a floating
action button to your app you'll need to
add this code to your Gradle file and
you'll notice here that says 22-point
2.0 that is for the build tools of when
I made this app right now I think it's
twenty twenty four point four point four
so use whatever is the latest and
greatest for your app so next thing
you'll need to do is add a bit of code
XML code for the floating action button
and we can see here at the top where it
says app fab size equals normal that's
saying that's going to be a 56 dip
floating action button it's going to
have an elevation of six depths and when
you press it it's going to elevate to 12
dips and then another thing you'll need
to do is the fab requires you to have
the theme
derive from app compat so if you start
up a normal app in Android studio
usually it will give you the top which
is material you really shouldn't use
material because it's not backward or
forward compatible use the one on the
bottom so if you have a material light
beam you can just change it to theme
that app compat that light okay so
coordinator layout is a new layout in a
material design that allows you to kind
of control how different elements
interact and move around the screen so
here is an example of a coordinator
layout and let me go widescreen on this
so you can see it a little bit better so
the coordinator layout is our outermost
layout and then we have an app bar
layout inside of that that app bar
layout kit contain a collapsing toolbar
which would be a collapse toolbar layout
or something like that have your general
recycler view the replacement for
ListView of course and then your
floating action button down here
and I can give you a link for this at
the end one of the instructors that I
did the course with Roman Nurik created
this visualizer
all right oh and I forgot how to demo
but my Android studio is did not reload
so give me a second
alright so while I'm waiting for that to
load I'm going to talk about snack bar
now snack bars are like a coordinator
layout friendly toast message so your
toast message kind of shows up
semi-transparent over top of your app
and it just doesn't give you context it
doesn't give you anything to like act
upon for your app snack bars can contain
an action so if you delete a message and
you're like oh man I didn't mean to
delete that you can have a undo action
and click that they can also be
dismissed and it will move the fab out
of place vertically if there is one
because the resting position of the fab
and the snack bar are at the same
elevation you see if my android studio
has started up and doo-doo-doo-doo
very sad
apologize for this day time guys we had
some technical difficulties so I had to
reboot my computer when a dyno I was
going to say once
here
all right let's uh move on for a little
bit and wait for that to come up all
right so the way that you make a snack
bar is similar to a toast message you
have your before this you will have done
a get view by ID for your snack bar or
if you're using a butter knife or
something like that somehow to get the
the widget for your snack bar and you
call make with your message and then the
duration of how long you want to show
and then show if you want to add an
action to that you would add the
function call to set action with an
onclicklistener
and a color for that text to show up and
let's see if we're loaded yeah we're
cool reloaded all right so um so this is
why I was talking about with a
coordinator layout where we have a view
with and expanded app bar here and we
have a recycler view of elements and
coordinator layout automatically knows
to scroll up and compress that collapse
bar view for us we don't really have to
do all that much but to say this is what
the expanded size should be this is what
the compressor size should be and it
knows when to scroll either just the
list or the list and the app bar any
questions before I move on all right
cool all right so next thing we talk
about is bold graphic design this is the
part of the material design spec that
comes from great print design so the
first thing is the gestalt laws are
grouping and this is kind of a trick
from your brain for how you perceive the
world so for instance in this room I can
see that there are a bunch of kids on
the side bunch of young adults so I
might assume that they are related that
they're from the same school because
they're wearing the same thing and
that's kind of what the gestalt law
group
do based off of proximity or similarity
your mind kind of makes assumptions on
how things are and and tries to bring
order to a chaotic world so for a quick
example we have two views up here the
one on the far right is it looks like
it's a bunch of avatar type images
circular images with rectangles next to
it just as I was mentioned before
because all of the circular images are
similar I would it would be easy to
assume that those are the same type of
image tools might be an avatar for a
person and the rectangles are equally
similar there probably a description for
a person and because the regular
rectangular ones are close to the
avatars they're probably related they're
probably describing the avatar
there's a lot more than that but that's
all I want to give you so I didn't bore
you so getting back to some kind of
nuts-and-bolts stuff in material design
the layouts are laid out with an eight
dip grid and a four dip grid for text
and they're a bunch of key lines that
allow you to line up things so you can't
see it very much in here but for this
mobile screen it expects it to be 16
dips from the left edge and then there's
a 72 dip if you're using like avatars or
something like that it helps you line up
things so another thing that you should
be using your design is great use of
color color provides cohesion across
grains
it makes us kind of feel things so in
certain certain countries certain colors
are are not as good and it's kind of the
same in in the US where if you see a red
you might think to stop you might see a
green you might think to go it's other
things that like that that kind of tie
into the psychology of your culture and
you as a person
so you should think about your colors
vary a lot so what if you're bad at
picking colors so there are two sites
that you can go and pick colors one is
material palette where it takes it
allows you to if this will load you can
easily select a color palette by
selecting two colors that will show up
when they do okay and there they are all
right so I could pick a indigo and a
purple and basically what it does is it
applies an algorithm to to say this is
what your primary color is going to be
and the color for your dark primary
color and light primary color and then
also for your accent color the other
site is Adobe color and I have the wrong
thing there but so Doby color is a
website where it allows you it has a
giant color wheel and you can pick one
color and it kind of show you what the
complementary colors or contrasting
colors and stuff like that is so use
that so if you're not moved by that
you're still bad find a designer buy
them a notebook they really like
notebooks and hipster stuff like that so
this is kind of what material palette
was doing with picking the colors so
material designed your colors range from
a 50 value which is the very lightest in
that that tint all the way down to a 900
the darkest you should select a 500 for
your primary color and then bump up a
couple of steps to a 700 for your status
bars down to 300 for your secondary bars
and then each color also has an accent
range from a 100 to a 700 generally an a
200 work well so this is that same
palette that we
selected for material palette and one of
the other things that I forgot to
mention about material palette is that
it allows you to download your colors
for the web and for Android you can
download in XML format to just drop into
your apps
alright so typography couple definitions
a font or a typeface is a specific style
of writing a a set of tax or characters
a font family is a group that are
equally influenced by that same style
but they might have slight differences
here and there and a font weight is
basically the thickness of a font and
the style is generally up whether it's
italic or normal and I will skip that
for a second so here's kind of example
of everything that lives in Roboto so
all of them have the general designs
characteristics of Roboto but you can
see that there is a regular version
there's a condensed a mono space and a
slab font
it also has different weights from the
thin all the way down to the black and
then bold and italic so you can set a
different font in your app by using the
code up top if you have a textview or
anything that derives from a textview
and add to font families of the
differents and surf's and the textile
and you'll notice that there is a bold
style down there generally you don't
want to use bold just because it kind of
programmatically makes bold for you as
opposed to a font that was specifically
made for that and you can also use a
custom font in your app by using this
code here I have a true type font that I
downloaded into my assets directory and
then I create the asset
and then for the textview I'm just
setting the typeface one thing to keep
in mind is that on attach you need to do
things in unattached because if you do
in an uncreate because of the fragment
life cycle there's a small time after
you create a fragment before it's
attached to an activity so get activity
get access acts sets will result in an
error and crash your app and these are
all the different sizes that are preset
and in android from display for all the
way down to button and you can Ollie
there's a flash flood warning for people
on TV so these are all the different
types that you can use so it kind of
shows you that you can still use one set
font and have it be very different and
very engaging so to the far right that
is the same UI but using the same font
sizes and as it comes closer to me it
uses different font weights and
different font styles and like the
header is using a slap font and
different colors and stuff like that so
you can stay with you can stay within
Roboto and not worry about it so my pro
tips for Android typography is never use
dips for font sizes you always use SP
which is scalable scale independent
pixels which allows your font to be
resized if the user has a large or
setting or small setting yeah yeah
yes okay that question was the grid is
in dips but the font are in sp yes the
grid that you're you're using the grip
for alignment but the font itself is
going to be an SP and there is like this
weird conversion of how to convert SP to
dips it's in the course and it's really
weird but yeah I I was I was freaked out
by that too so it's no big deal you can
use for voto for all the things in your
app and all fronts are not created equal
just because you have a really fun that
you think is really awesome
it might not scale down very well or the
creator of the font might have not made
many weights of it so just bear in mind
that so just quickly point imagery I
generally try to think of it by asking
myself a couple questions is the brand
or product I'm designing for Sirius is
it playful is it stylish depending on
the answer to those questions is going
to determine what types of imagery I'm
going to use and for a specific concept
is imagery easily relate like if it's
something very abstract like sinking
where a illustration will work better
than an actual like picture of a person
standing at a computer and who is your
intended user or market and these are
things to think about with fonts as well
so if you're making a product a
performance app a performance profiler
app you wouldn't want to use a cursive
font because that doesn't seem very
serious it doesn't seem fast to your
users any questions on that for a
move-on cool
all right so a motion motion should be
instructive and guide your users through
your app this is not the time to say
look at all this cool stuff that I can
have was around the screen so it
shouldn't distract them confuse them and
it should be generally orderly this goes
back into the things about Gestalt where
we want to bring order to the to the
chaos and you don't want to freak out
your users by having all these elements
coming in from all different sizes so a
transition manager was introduced in
KitKat 4.4 it allows creation to
transition in code or XML and it does an
insane amount of the heavy lifting for
you have any of you guys ever had to
wire up an animation by yourself in
Android ok so you guys know my pain of
using like the old way in object
animator and property animators and
stuff like that so here is kind of an
example that I did that only took a
couple lines of code and basically when
you click the button it shuffles the
image off of the screen so that actually
is doing a lot of stuff there so the
first thing is doing is capturing the
start state of all the views then
capturing the end state and it's
creating and creating an animator to
interpolate between the two and then
based off of what type of transition
type I set it's going to say okay using
that those values let me make this
animation so this is the code that I use
to do that so I have a slide transition
and I set the slight edge to the top of
the screen so it's going to slide things
off the top of the screen and then down
here in transition manager I say I tell
it to begin a delay transition and it's
using that slide and then I do all the
things that I'm going to do to the to
the view in this case it's just telling
the image to disappear so instead of
just fading off the screen it's going to
use that slide and slide up the top
slide off the top
there are a bunch of transition types
that were introduced in API 19 and API
21 I showed you slide by default if you
don't set a transition it's going to use
Auto transition which will use a
combination of like sliding and I think
exploding and fading and stuff like that
it kind of has a set of things that it
will kind of automatically move the
things off the screen activity
transitions when you're moving between
activity this is another place where you
can have instructive motion to guide
your user by having a specific
transition when they go into or out of a
specific activity so if you have
activity a and activity B when you when
you go from A to B B's enter at activity
transition is going to be called and
when you return from B to a well a is
exit restart so if I have X of T a and
activity B when I'm going from A to B
A's exit activity is going to exit
transition is going to fire in B's
interactivity is going to transitions
going to fire and then when I'm
returning from B to a B's return and
then AZ re-enter is going to fire
okay okay the question was it seems like
it could be really jarring if there if
there are transitions on both sides and
if you have a bad exit or a weird enter
the answer is yes
there certainly can be a question REE
comment was do you have to keep them
looking saying there are a couple things
that you can do like something I'm going
to mention in this library here shared
element transitions you can basically
say I want this object or these groups
of objects that exist in this view and
also exist in this view to move to
transition so a good way to show it to
you is just an example here so we have a
headed here
it's okay
coordinated motion Oh Harris sorry about
that okay so here's one for a shared
activity a shared element transition so
I have these sets of avatars and if I
click one of them it's going to make a
transition into the next view and that
one's was slightly different because
that wasn't inter or accident that was
just a yeah a share transition I'm
basically seeing this set of objects
that I have existed in this screen and
exist in this next screen so I want them
I want you to figure out how to
transition between the two states
so this is another place where it kind
of automatically does things for you so
this would be a way where you would
avoid having to think of how is a going
to transition how is B going to
transition and just stick to these are
the important parts of a that should
transition over to B these are fragments
yeah and let me pull up that code for
you have this code those coordinated
motion
yep question
a question was is there a limit of total
transitions you can have no there is not
but you should try to do as few as
possible like you should try to do just
enough to kind of move things along just
because one of the things you'll notice
if you have a person who has a really
old phone there the Trent it might lag
on their phone if if you have like 15
transitions firing off good question
thanks for asking that and just okay so
here's this code right here that kind of
controlled it you have a shared element
enter transition and this one only set
imposing wait wait oh so there's a
shared element enter transition it only
sets the inter transition in this
example and it just has a simple boolean
check of should it move on a curve or
should just be a straight motion back
and that's another thing that I didn't
mention before you should try to move
things on curves as much as possible
going back to slides did that quickly on
interpolators this also goes with
transitions you can pro matically code
how you want something to move and there
a bunch that exist in android these are
kind of the three that you should
probably use at the most and you can
kind of notice like if you have a long
duration of 300 milliseconds it makes
your app look like it's slow but if you
have something like 300 it looks zippy
and fast so generally you should try and
keep your transitions to be about 300
milliseconds give or take and kind of
adjust from there too
see how it feels and quickly on adaptive
design how much time we have oh we're
good so you should think about your
content first and not your device you
shouldn't and what I mean by that is you
shouldn't code for a specific device and
instead let the content tell you where
things should break up if you have
limited developer resources having a
breakpoint at 600 dips is a good
starting point but there are many many
others that you can have so in material
design spec
there's one for very small screens it
says let me see if I can blow this up
nope doesn't work image um so there's
like 480 600 there's a
there are a bunch of different sizes so
a good starting point to start with 600
and then depending on your user base and
whatever form factors you want to
support do more or less there are a
couple of different strategies for
managing space so moving when you're
moving from a smaller screen to your
bigger screen you can reveal more of the
other content that you were showing on
the smaller screen so you might do a
master-detail view where you show
multiple fragments on the screen you can
also reflow the content to just use more
of the screen or if neither of those
work you can just kind of expand the
white space around your content and
dividing is the opposite of revealing
just splitting your your UI into
multiple fragments so to implement your
breakpoints you should be using your
qualifiers like landscape and portrait
and the ones at the bottom are for
specific densities you should not use
the small medium large qualifiers
because those are really fuzzy and
caused problems and that was it as far
as content I have but definitely open
for questions so